FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Laura: NOW BACK TO THE
BILLBOARD WHERE BILL HEMMER IS
STANDING BY WITH THE LATEST.
I IT GETS CLOSER AND CLOSER.
>> IT DOES.
AUTOMATIC RECOUNT, LAURA.
STATEWIDE IF IT'S LESS THAN .5%.
GOT IT?
THAT'S WHERE WE BEGIN HERE.
LOOK WHERE WE ARE.
WE'RE .9% WITH DAVID McCORMICK
AND DR. OZ.
YOU HEARD KATHY BARNETTE AND HER
SPEECH.
YOU ASK YOURSELF, LAURA, WHERE
ARE THE REMAINING VOTES.
WHERE DO YOU FIND THEM
THROUGHOUT THE KEYSTONE STATE IN
THE 67 COUNTIES ON THE BOARD
HERE.
JUST A REMINDER, THIS IS
PITTSBURGH IN THE WEST.
HARRISBURG IN THE CENTER PART OF
THE STATE.
IF YOU LACK AT THE OUTSTANDING
VOTE THAT REMAINS NOW, YOU GO
SOUTHEAST OF PITTSBURGH,
WESTMORELAND COUNTY, THAT IS, BY
THE WAY, THE PLACE WHERE DONALD
TRUMP WENT AND HAD THE RALLY
WITH DR. OZ ABOUT 1 1/2 WEEKS
AGO.
PITTSBURGH HERE.
WESTMORELAND COUNTY.
RIGHT NOW A DECENT COUNTY, OUT
OF 67 COUNTIES, IT RANKS NUMBER
10 IN TERMS OF POPULATION.
THEY HAVE ABOUT 60% OF THE VOTE
REPORTING WHICH MEANS 40% IS
OUTSTANDING.
SIMPLE MATH.
THAT'S IN WESTMORELAND.
I WANT TO TAKE YOU ACROSS THE
STATE AND SHOW YOU THE
SOUTHEAST.
THIS IS PHILADELPHIA DOWN HERE.
THE GREEN AREA.
I SHOWED THESE A SHORT TIME AGO.
BUCKS COUNTY, STRONG POPULATION.
FOUR OUT OF 67.
A MOMENT AGO IT WAS REPORTING
THAT ONLY 18% OF THE VOTE WAS
IN.
IF THAT'S THE CASE, THEY HAVE A
WAYS TO GO.
>> MONTGOMERY COUNTY 3 OF 67.
THEY WERE REPORTING LESS THAN
HALF THE VOTE IN AT 40%.
STILL A WAYS TO GO THERE.
IN DELAWARE COUNTY, 5 OF 67.
THESE ARE -- A LOT OF FOLKS LIVE
HERE IN SOUTHEASTERN P.A.
THEY WERE AT 27% OF THE VOTE.
A LOT THERE IN SOUTHEASTERN
PENNSYLVANIA.
STILL OUTSTANDING.
THAT MAY MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE
WITH McCORMICK AND OZ AND
DETERMINE THE OUTCOME, THE
ULTIMATE OUTCOME HERE.
POP UP HERE.
THIS IS NOR HAMILTON COUNTY.
YOU CAN SEE OZ LEADING
McCORMICK.
THERE TOO, YOU HAVE ABOUT HALF
OF THE VOTE IS IN.
SO THERE'S MORE BALLOTS TO BE
COUNTED OUT THERE.
COME HERE TO LANCASTER,
PENNSYLVANIA HERE.
GOT IT.
THEY'RE AROUND THE SAME AREA AS
NORTHAMPTON.
THE SUSQUEHANNA RIVER HERE.
AMISH COUNTRY.
SOUTHERN PENNSYLVANIA.
RIGHT ALONG THE SOUTHERN BORDER
THERE.
LANCASTER IS REPORTING ABOUT 54%
OF THE VOTES IN.
SO THERE IS STILL -- I GET IN
SUMMARY, LAURA, WHAT I WOULD
TELL YOU AS OF 10:41 EAST COAST
TIME IN PENNSYLVANIA, YOU ARE
REALLY WAITING ON THIS PART OF
THE STATE HERE TO CLOCK IN AND
WE'LL SEE HOW MUCH THIS CHANGES.
SINCE WE'VE BEEN TALKING HERE,
WE'VE REDUCED THE COUNT TO .8%.
THIS NUMBER SAYS 95% OF THE VOTE
IN.
THAT IS THE ESTIMATED VOTE IN
BEGINNING THE NIGHT BASED ON
WHAT WE BELIEVE THROUGH THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS.
THAT NUMBER CAN CHANGE, GO
HIGHER OR LOWER DEPENDING WHEN
THE VOTES ARE TALLIED.
IF YOU GET A GOOD TURNOUT AS WE
SAW IN VIRGINIA, REMEMBER IT
WENT HIGHER AND HIGHER AND
DROPPED?
THAT'S BECAUSE OF TURNOUT.
THAT COULD BE THE CASE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE HERE.
AS WE STAND RIGHT NOW, LAURA,
YOU'RE AT .8%.
REMEMBER I SAID .5?
I THINK I TOLD YOU .5.
>> Laura: BILL, I'M SEEING THAT
RIGHT NOW McCORMICK IS UP 8 IN
ALLEGHENY COUNTY, WHICH IS A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE.
ALLEGHENY FOR HIM RIGHT NOW.
>> 8%.
>> GOOD MATH.
>> Laura: THAT'S KEY.
WE'RE MISSING KEY AREAS OF
PHILADELPHIA.
BILL, YOU'VE BEEN AROUND THIS
GAME SO MANY TIMES.
WHY IS IT THAT PHILADELPHIA
SEEMS TO ALWAYS COME IN LATE?
>> DEPENDS WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE.
>> Laura: OR IS IT JUST ME?
>> THE CITY OF PHILADELPHIA,
WHICH IS ALSO THECOUNTY OF
PHILADELPHIA, THE REASON WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT THAT A LOT,
IF YOU READ THIS A LITTLE BIT
HERE, LAURA, YOU'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT A TON OF VOTES.
IF THERE WERE A DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY AND BETWEEN LET'S SAY
FEDDERMAN, OKAY?
YOU SEE THE DIFFERENCE?
FEDDERMAN TODAY PICKED UP 35,000
VOTES ON HIS OWN.
CONOR LAMB CAME IN THIRD IN
PHILADELPHIA.
HE GOT 25,000.
ON THE REPUBLICAN TALLY, OZ IS
AT 7,500.
McCORMICK IS 5,000.
SO YOU CAN SEE, PHILADELPHIA,
THE CITY OF PHILADELPHIA IS
ABOUT 85/15 DEMOCRATS TO
REPUBLICANS.
SO JUST A SLIGHT DISTINCTION
THERE.
YOUR POINT IS WELL-TAKEN ABOUT
THE COLLAR COUNTIES HERE.
BUCKS, MONTGOMERY, DELAWARE.
>> Laura: LOOKS LIKE IN BUCKS
COUNTY, THE NUMBERS COMING IN
FOR McCORMICK ARE ALSO I GUESS
DECENT, CORRECT?
>> IN BUCKS COUNTY?
>> Laura: YES.
>> McCORMICK OF THE VOTES
TALLIES, 3,000 RAW VOTES.
OZ HAS 2,700.
OFFICIALLY, LAURA, BACK TO .9%.
>> Laura: WOW.
BILL, THIS IS -- IT'S SO GREAT